hi everyone
this talk is going to be about black box
uselessness a new method to compose
separations in cryptography
i'm joffra koutou and this is a joint
work with puya hashim and mohammad
mahmudi
so since from the distance the landscape
of cryptography might looks like
this we have a few islands of important
primitives such as key agreement
encryption signatures and a bunch of
assumptions that are used to build them
such as
rsa and ddh however
in reality the landscape of cryptography
looks much more like this to a
cryptographer
we have a tremendous amount of primitive
sometimes
tiny variants of each other and dozen
perhaps hundreds of different
cryptographic assumptions
which we use to build these primitives
and so this state of affair is quite
unfortunate because it's extremely hard
to analyze in isolation each of these
primitives and assumptions one by one
and the problem is we cannot hope to
prove them secure all at once because
they currently all rely on unproven
assumptions
such as the p versus np problem
so the goal of cryptographic reduction
which is one of the most important areas
of cryptography is to cope with this
unsatisfying side of affairs
by providing reductions between
cryptographic assumptions and
cryptographic primitives
showing that the existence of one
implies the existence
of the other so this has many advantages
first it allows to conceptually simplify
the landscape
into islands of equivalent primitives
it also provides sometimes unexpected
new connections between
different problems which have very
different structures
and also it allows to derive through
these connections new constructions of
various primitives
under well-studied assumptions
in the past few decades reduction-based
cryptography has enjoyed a tremendous
amount of successes um
if only if i were only to mention one in
the area of private key cryptography
the most fundamental assumption of all
is the assumption that there are one-way
functions so what's a one-way function
it is a function that can be evaluated
in the forward direction
in polynomial time but that cannot be
inverted in polynomial time by any
polynomial time adversary
and many other interesting primitives
have been shown
in the 90s to be actually equivalent to
the existence of one-way functions
this includes but is not limited to
zero-knowledge proof
commitment schemes pseudonym functions
signatures
stream ciphers and so on however
in countless other cases we are not
aware
of any reduction that will prove the
existence of one primitive
based on the existence of another
primitive
for example we don't know if we can base
the existence of
public encryption on the existence of
one way function
this is a bit unsatisfying especially
because
search reductions must exist if we
believe that one way functions exist
and if we believe that public encryption
also exists
then there has to be a reduction that
bases public encryption on the existence
of one-way function
consider for example the following
reduction it simply ignores
the one-way function and builds the
public encryption from scratch
so a lack of a reduction between two
cryptographic primitives
can be at best a limitation of our
techniques for developing cryptographic
reductions
so is it possible to identify what
limitation is it
well the crucial insight in this area
was brought to us by impagliatsu and
hudish
in 1989. what they observed
was that most cryptographic reductions
are black box
this means that these reductions are
oblivious to the specific
way the source primitive was implemented
and also oblivious to the specific way
the adversary against the source
primitive
is implemented slightly more formally
there is a black box reduction from a
primitive b to a primitive a
if there exists a construction of b
which is
this construction is a pair of algorithm
ps
such that given any implementation of
the primitive a any concrete
construction of the primitive a
whenever this concrete construction of
a is efficient then
p that internally uses access to this
efficient construction a
is an efficient implementation of b
and there is a reduction s
that transforms an adversary any
adversary
that will break the
primitive p that implements
b it converts any other source that
breaks this primitive p
into another adversary that actually
breaks
uh the primitive a now when we have this
form of reduction
um we can start proving that it is not
possible to find a black box reduction
between two important cryptographic
primitives and this is what impact liats
and hudish did
in their seminal 1989 paper by proving
that there exists no black box reduction
from key agreement to one-way functions
so bathing one on the other is exactly
asking can we base
all of modern cryptography on the
most primitive possible assumption in
cryptography which is the existence
of one-way functions so since then there
has been
a tremendous number of black box
separations between cryptographic
primitives
and those explain the limits of our
techniques but also they guide future
constructions
because they roll out a very large class
of methods
nowadays we have dozens of black box
separation perhaps hundreds of them
however there is a strong caveat
to all these black box separations
and the caveat is the following that i
have this primitive p
in the center of this picture here and i
it was black box separated
from many other primitives a b c and so
on
so for each of these primitives i know
that there is no black box construction
of p
from this primitive however
any such impossibility result only rules
out
the possibility of constructing p in a
black box way
from a single primitive say a alone
in taken in isolation
so maybe i can prove that a taken in
isolation cannot be used in any black
box construction of p
and there is no black box construction
of p from a in isolation
and maybe it's the same holds for b but
any such impossibility result says
nothing about what happens when i start
combining primitives
the problem is that in crypto we do that
a lot modern cryptography is
all about taking a bunch of primitives
and assumptions
and saying that if you combine them
together then you can build this new
primitive
so black box import visibility results
innocence are extremely limited in what
they teach us
because they only tell us that we have
no hope of using a primitive in
isolation to build another one
but they say nothing about this whether
this primitive
might be extremely useful in a black box
construction
of p that might possibly involve other
primitives
and this creates a very undesirable
situation because
if we want to rule out the possibility
of combining various primitives
to provide a black box construction of p
then the only thing we currently know
that we can do
is to prove black box separations
between p
and any subsets of the primitive that we
want to show cannot jointly imply p
so in this work the core question that
we ask is whether we can
achieve a much more meaningful and
powerful notion
of black box separation that in
particular would be composable
so what do i mean by composable i would
like to be able to say that
um if a cannot be used to build p
via this new notion and b also cannot be
used to build p via this
notion then combining them together will
not help me be building p
so what we want is a way of saying that
primitive cannot possibly be useful
in any black box construction of the
primitive p
the way we define it is as follow a
primitive a
is black box useless for p
if given any auxiliary primitive z
if there exists a black box construction
of p
from r a together with z
then there must already exist a
construction of p
from z alone
so given this notion of black box
uselessness
there is a very easy composability crm
which says that
if a primitive a is black box useless
for p and b
is black box use less for p then taken
together
a and b are also black box useless for p
how to prove it well suppose that um
we have a black box construction of p
from a b
and some auxiliary primitive z we can
group b
and z together into a single primitive z
prime and we use the fact that a
is black box useless for p to say that a
and z
prime black box imply p this implies
that z prime already implies p
alone so now we have a black box
construction of p
from b and z so only the primitive z
prime
but since b itself is black box useless
for p
then a construction of p from b and z
implies the black box construction of p
from z
alone and so the pair of primitive a b
is jointly black box useless for
building p
okay
so in our paper um we put first the
study
of black box uselessness our main
contributions are four-fold
first the definitional framework we
identify
many flavor flavors of this notion of
black box uselessness that we put first
in particular we use the taxonomy
of um black box separation
that was um given in the rtvo4 framework
and we defined blackbox uselessness
in this taxonomy so for all possible
variants of the notion of black box
separations
we also show how to generalize our
notion to other settings like black box
use lessons with respect to a subset of
all possible primitives
or black box looseness uselessness in
efficient construction that shows the
limitations
of the use of a primitive
if we do not make sufficiently many
calls to the primitive
in a black box construction and we
formally prove the
composition theorem that that i sketched
on
the previous slide then we
ask ourselves what black box separations
methods in the literature
can be directly generalized to provide a
stronger black box uselessness result
and we identify one large such class of
methods
which is known as the combining out
paradigm
in this paradigm we show that
black box separations they relativize
so this compiling out method which kind
of allows to
remove a primitive from
a construction in a black box way
this uh separation message usually
relativizes in the sense that it
can still be done in the presence of an
auxiliary oracle so this implies that
it actually provides a stronger result
which is black box uselessness
so this gives us kind of for free a
large number
of black box uselessness results between
important cryptographic primitives
then we ask um what is perhaps the most
fundamental question
about black box uselessness which is
whether one-way functions
are black box useless for building key
agreement remember that by impact
liaison radius
1989 we know that there is no black box
construction of key agreement
from one way function but perhaps one
way functions
um are useful in building key agreements
and so we conjecture that it's not the
case we conjure that if there is any
construction of key agreement
that makes a black box use of a one-way
function and other primitives
then we can remove the one-way function
and get a black box instruction of
key agreement from the auxiliary
primitive alone
we do not fully prove this conjecture
but we provide a preliminary result
in this direction by showing that one
way functions are black box useless
in any construction of key agreement
that is unbalanced
in the sense that one of the two parties
makes only a constant number of queries
to the one-way function
and the other can make an arbitrary
number of queries so the one-way
function
and both parties can make an arbitrary
number of queries to the auxiliary
primitive
so given this restriction we can prove
that one way functions are black box
useless for key agreements
and perhaps the most interesting open
program left by our work
is to remove this restriction
and then the last thing we study is
whether one of my functions could
possibly
be black box helpful for other
primitives
so this is the opposite of black box
uselessness
and we conjectures that black one-way
functions are actually black box helpful
for building collision rays and hash
functions but i will not have time
to talk about this in this talk
but the definition and composition crm
we already briefly covered in the
previous slide
and in the main focus of the rest of the
talk
will be our core result which is that
one way functions
are black box useless for unbalanced key
agreements
and before that i will just on the next
slide give a quick teaser
on the list of results that we obtain as
a byproduct of showing
that the compiling out paradigm can be
extended to the blackbox users region
as i said black box separation via the
combining out paradigm or a device
so a few consequences are um
that one-way permutation
a black box use less in many kind of
efficient construction
and using more research results we show
that one-way functions our black box use
less
for constructing approximate
indistinguishability obfuscation a very
important cryptographic primitive
and this can be expanded to actually
show that
a large number of very strong
cryptographic primitives are all black
box useless
for constructing approximating
distinguishability obfuscation
so moving out to the main results um of
the paper
are one-way functions blackbox useless
for building key agreement
the impact let's reduce black box
separation works as follow
we consider a situation where we have a
candidate construction of key agreement
that makes a black box use of an
arbitrary one-way function so we have
two parties
alice and bob and they both have access
to this one-way function oracle
and they both can make polynomial number
of queries to it and then ice and bob
interact
they exchange messages and at the end of
the protocol they output keys so key for
alice and the key for bob
and the protocol is said to be correct
if we have sufficiently high probability
those two keys are equal and there is
also an attacker
an eavesdropper eve that observes the
transcripts and can also
interact with the one way function
oracle
and which tries to find out which key
which join key was generated by alice
and bob
so the core observation that underlies
the
black box separation by impagliato and
rudish
is that since the construction is
assumed to be black box
then it must work given any
implementation of the one-way function
even an even
even an inefficient one
so the core id is the following we will
implement the one-way function with a
pair of oracles which is a random oracle
so truly random oracle that has a
uniformly random truth table
and a p-space oracle
impact let's showed that even in the
presence of a p-space oracle
a random oracle remains a one-way
function
so it is a valid way to instantiate our
one-way function even though it's not an
efficient one
and then the crux of the proof is to
show that given this particular
implementation
of the one-way function there
exists an efficient attack that makes
only a polynomial number of queries to
the
to the random morocco um against
any such key agreement
so how does the attack work i'm only
going to describe a simplified version
that was described later um by brackets
and that only apply that only works when
uh the
um key agreement protocol is perfectly
correct
but the essence remains the same so
essentially what i say can be
generalized to the original proof for
the general case
it's just a bit more tedious to describe
so the intuition behind that underlies
this separation
is that now since the one-way function
is instantiated using a true random
oracle
each time alice and bob makes queries
that are not intersection queries in the
sense that they are not queried that
they
are both going to make to the uh random
oracle
then these queries essentially do not
matter for the result because they are
completely random and the other party
knows nothing about them
what truly matters is the queries that
alice and bob
will both manage to do to the random
oracle
so those queries are called intersection
queries
so the goal of the eavesdropper eve will
be to find out
these intersection queries the way eve
does that
is um as follows she will assemble in
her head
many views of the interaction between
alice and bob
in the in a way that these views are
consistent
with the transcript of the interaction
between alice and bob
but she will not uh sample these views
by carrying the true random oracle
she will sample these views with respect
to a random record that
she simulates in her head
so when she does that she obtains a list
of the queries that alice made in this
simulation
each time she obtains these quarries she
takes all these queries that she made in
her head
to a fake random miracle and make them
to the tour on the moracle
obtaining the interest of alice
they're sorry the answers of the ronald
miracle then in the next round of attack
she redoes the same to resample a view
of alice which is consistent
with the current transcript but also
consistent with all the queries that she
made previously to the true random
oracle
and she keeps at the end of that making
all queries made by her simulation of
alice to the true random oracle
updating her set of previous queries
and always sampling views in a way that
is consistent with all these previous
queries and
one can see that each time she does that
either um she did not miss
any intersection queries in which case
uh she will
um sorry uh either
there was no intersection queries
between alice and bob
in which case her simulation
of the random america in her head
corresponds to a valid choice of random
morocco
there is no contradiction because she's
using around a miracle which she never
queries
where bob carried it so
um this simulated random miracle
together with the true queries of bob
correspond to valid possibility of rona
moraca
so by the perfect correctness of the key
agreement each time this is the case
she will compute the right key
or one of the queries that she made
to a simulated on a miracle and that she
will later make to the tour on a miracle
is a query that also
that bob already made but this can only
happens
um as many times as the number of
queries bob makes
to the random morocco so if
eve repeats this attack uh twice the
number of queries made by bob
plus one then we are guaranteed that
the number of times where this bad event
happens is bounded by the number of
cards made by bob
so in the majority of this situation eve
will compute the right key
so by just computing the majority of all
the keys which we assume to be bits here
but we can generalize to larger
keys um is guaranteed to find
with very high probability is the key
that alice and bob agreed upon
which contradicts the security of the
key agreement protocol
okay so that was for the impact leader
of british
black box separation determine their
functionality agreement so let's keep
that in our mind
and now let's think whether we think
that one way function
should be black box useless for key
agreement or not
so some of you might be familiar with
the notion of cryptographic obfuscation
which i already briefly mentioned
when i listed some results so
those of you who are familiar with it
might recall
that obfuscation alone does not imply
key agreement in a black box way
but obfuscation plus one-way functions
together can be used to build
uh key agreements so at first sight it
might seem that one-way functions cannot
be black box useless for building key
agreement
however this construction of key
agreement from obfuscation plus one way
function
is not black box and something which is
interesting is that actually
the previous proof that i gave you by
impact on rudish
already implies that this is inherent in
the sense that
um there is no black box construction of
one-way function
of a key agreement from one-way
functions
plus obfuscation why is it the case
simply because well a p space oracle
implies an obfuscation oracle
how well obfuscation means that you can
scramble a circuit in a way that
you cannot distinguish uh which circuit
was crumbled between any pair of
equivalent circuits
so the way of scrambling the circuit uh
given the p-space oracle is just to use
it to find
the lexicographically first circuit
which is equivalent
in the sense of having the same input
output behavior
to the circuit that we want to obfuscate
so this clearly gives a perfect
obfuscation which is perfectly secure
so that means that the
attack by impaggets on radish actually
already proves
that one way functions together with
obfuscation does not black box imply key
agreement
because there exists an implementation
of the one-way function with verona
morocco
and of the obfuscation with a p-space
oracle
such that there is an attack against a
resulting protocol
an efficient attack and i forgot to
mention previously but the peace space
foreign the previous proof was used by
eve
to make this sampling of use of alice
efficient so it's an efficient attack
so in fact um
we claim and we believe
that this is inherent in the sense that
one-way functions are black box useless
for building key agreement
the dream result which we would really
like to prove will be the following
for any primitive z if there exists a
black box construction
of key agreement from a one-way function
and
this other primitive z then there must
already exist
a black box construction of key
agreement from the primitive z alone
we prove something very close to these
results but there are two
main caveats the first one
in blue here is an artifact of our proof
techniques
our result only applies to the notion of
infinitely often one-way functions
it's an infinitely often one-way
function is
a one-way functions which is guaranteed
to be secure only for
an infinite set of security parameters
so we show a black box uselessness of
infinitely often one-way functions
for key agreement and our proof works
for key
standard programming or infinitely often
key agreement
the second limitation is a much more
limiting one so represented in right
here
we only managed to prove that this
separation holds
when we limit ourselves to key agreement
protocols
in which one of the parties makes only a
constant number of queries to the
one-way function
first we start back from this
empagliazordis attack
so alice and bob they have access to a
noise function
and an auxiliary oracle z and we
implement this one-way function
with the random variable and the p-space
oracle as we previously explained
and we stopped the attack of impact.over
dish so eve starts creating many views
of
alice in our head which are consistent
with the transcript of the interaction
between alice and bob
with respect to a simulated random
oracle but now to do that she has to
sample this view
uh consistent with the transcript the
similarity from the miracle but the true
oracle z
the problem is that this sampling can
involve doing
exponentially many rejection sampling
of views and checking whether they are
consistent with the transcript
but this in general will require
exponentially many calls to z
so the previous proof of impagliatsu and
rudish
breaks down as soon as we add another
oracle z
and in fact this is uh unavoidable
because um
we could not hope to prove that we can
break any construction of
uh key agreement given any auxiliary
primitive z
z could be itself a key agreement
primitive for all we know
so to get around this issue the core
observation
of our work is that when eve
is trying to sample a view consistent
with a transcript
and the cause of bob uh to the true
oracle z
this can be formulated as sampling a
pre-image
of some efficient function which uh
which is given oracle access to z
so this what is this function it's a
function that
is given oracle access to z and c uh
simulates a random oracle so it's just
this is just a huge random tape
then it turns alice and bob internally
doing the calls to the true
primitive oracle d and outputting the
transcript
and now given this transcript we want to
inverse sample views for alice and bob
which are consistent with it
so this is very close to the task of
inverting
a function an efficient function so the
core id
is to make a case disjunction based on
whether there exists
or not one way functions relative to z
the id is the following support that
there exists no one-way functions
relative to z
in which case we prove that it is
possible to efficiently
sample a pre-image to
any efficient function given oracle
access to z
the other case is that there might exist
a one-way function relative to z
but if this is the case then we do not
need
the one-way function in the construction
in the first place
because we can simply build a key
agreement from z
alone by using z to build the one-way
function
and then using the together with the
one-way function built from z
to instantiate the one-way function in
this construction of key agreement that
we assume existed
and then we get an efficient
construction of key agreement from z
alone
so this is really the the core of the
proof
now i told you that we don't actually
manage to prove the full results
and that's because in these proof
techniques there are two caveats
the first caveat is that in this proof
techniques
we crucially need that bob makes only a
constant number of queries
so take any function that makes n
queries to the actual
auxiliary primitive z and assume that
there is no one-way function
relative to z so we can invert it say in
a quadratic amount of curry
so we really break in a very strong
sense all possible one way functions
so how does eve implement the impeller
attack
given this one-way function inverter
well we first consider the one-way
function
that samples the transcripts of the
interaction between alice and bob
it makes some number end of chorus to z
and
alice does the first round of the attack
in time
n squared by inverting this function
but then at the next round the one-way
function that alice needs to invert now
is not only the one that samples a
transcript
because alice sorry eve now needs to
do this premixed champagne consistent
with a set of queries that you made
previously
so the only way to do that is to
consider the function
that samples the transcript in the first
round
then computes um the
the the queries around the moroccan
and then samples the transcript
consistent with this
with this function with this uh chorizos
around the molecule
but that means that the function that
eve must invert after the second round
itself already involves in the forward
direction the inversion in the first
round
so this is a function that takes time
say about n squared
so inverting it takes time n to the four
and if the attack continue at the third
round
then the forward direction of the
one-way function that
eve must invert takes time n to the four
so inverting it can take time n to the
eighth
and so by continuing this way we see
that after
repeating the attack a number of time
which is proportional to the number of
quarries of bob
because at the number of rounds of
attack in the impact let's radish attack
then the complexity of the attack here
would be
um would grow exponentially
like even doubly exponentially with the
number of queries made by bob
so to make this efficient we need to
restrict the number of queries made by
bob to be a constant
and of course since we can always
exchange the roles of alice and bob
all we need is that at least one of the
parties
makes only a constant number of queries
to the one-way function and an arbitrary
number of queries to the auxiliary
primitive
and this is really the core limitation
of a result
the second caveat that i mentioned is a
restriction to
infinitely often one-way functions the
reason for this kvl is as follow
recall that eve must invert a number of
runway functions
in this attack that is proportional to
the number of queries made by bob
relative to z the problem is that if we
only assume that in existence of one-way
function
um this assumption only gives us
an infinitely often one saying that
there is no annoying function which is
secure for all large enough security
parameters
means that there exists an efficient
inverter
for an infinite number of security
parameters
but now we have many one-way functions
to invert and we have no guarantee that
we'll be able to find
an efficient inverter that for a given
security parameter
will be able to simultaneously invert
all these one-way functions
for each of these one-way functions in
isolation our inverter inverts them
on an an infinite amount of security
parameters but there might not be any
single security parameters where it
inverts them all
so to get around this point uh we make
the case distinction based
on the existence or in existence of
infinitely often one-way functions
relative to z since the inexistence of
an infinitely often one of functions
relative to z
now gives us an inverter that
succeeds at inverting all possible one
way functions
simultaneously for all large enough
security parameters
and this limitation is less strong in
this because there is no known example
of black box reduction
that does not already translate to the
infinity of a regime so this still gives
a pretty meaningful result
so there are several interesting open
questions left in our work
the core one maybe is whether we can
extend our result to all key agreement
protocols and not only those where
one of the parties makes only a constant
number of queries to the one-way
function
we conjure that it can be done
another interesting question is to
expand the number of separations
techniques that we know how to expand to
the black box uselessness
result so uh to to get um
a larger amount of meaningful black box
uselessness results
um in cryptography and it was
it would also be very interesting to
prove that one-way functions are
actually black box helpful for collision
rates and hash functions
we also conjecture this to be the case
and we discuss it in the paper but we
could not prove the conjecture we could
only relate it
to other interesting conjectures related
to random oracles
so that's all for my talk i hope you
enjoyed it
i'm i'll be happy to see you at the live
talk